hi this is tim cavanaugh a recent TV
we're in downtown LA at the Staples
Center where labor O'Malley is being
held to protest a local routes and to
show solidarity with government
employees in the state of Wisconsin they
rally to bring workers together across
the country to support in this case the
United Food and Commercial Workers Union
or an impasse with their employers
Ralphs yes Ralph's absolutely what
happened in Wisconsin shouldn't happen
you know do you see any difference
between public employees and private
sector employees like you're you're
working for American which is a private
company see any difference when it's
government workers no do you think
socialism is coming to Egypt I don't
know if it's coming to Egypt you know is
that yeah when in a capitalist system
what happens to locals a small portion
of hands and with knees up showed an
example but what can happen when workers
the students get together
the coke anybody know what the problem
is over here with the devil how did you
get to be so evil no answer from the
devil as always he leaves us guessing at
the true nature of evil now what do you
think of runaway production do you think
California needs film production tax
credit I just want to remind our viewers
that Ralph's exploits its employees but
as these happy Union customers can tell
you it has great prices efforts to roll
back future accruals
for currently working people I think
it's part of the effort by big business
to not pay the cost of what the laborers
work for the things they produce they
produce all this stuff but they don't
want to give the people to make this
stuff nothin right now what do you think
the biggest threat is to labor where
it's
big business offshore McCool doors in
Mexico China boo shake who do you think
is is on the other side right now who's
really your your biggest problem
Republicans lesbians are United for cook
blocking how do you intend to do it what
do you how do you keep them back hey
we're here out in the streets were
marching and people are voting with
their feet today
the coats have a history of being pretty
liberal on social issues but gay
marriage things like that gay marriage
you know it's all good to me but and
what's true is that labor has never been
really a left or right issue it's a poor
enriched issue I quit my Union they're
my brothers and sisters